こんしゅうのざっくばらん
エーアイアシスタント育成ツール
せんしゅう、MulmoClaudeを何と呼べば良いのか悩んでいると書きましたが、ようやく答えを見つけました。
「エーアイアシスタント育成ツール」です。
「エーアイアシスタント」とは、私たちに24時間一緒にいて、仕事や生活に関わるさまざまなことのアシスタントをしてくれるエーアイのことです（特定の仕事を人間の代わりにしてくれる「エーアイエージェント」とは異なるコンセプトです。
人間に例えれば、「エーアイアシスタント」は秘書・執事、「エーアイエージェント」は弁護士・料理人・庭師に相当します）。
「エーアイアシスタント」というと、メタのスマートグラスを思い浮かべる人が多いと思いますが、スマートグラスはエーアイアシスタントにアクセスするデバイスの一つでしかなく、その実態はデバイス上ではなく、インターネット上にあることが重要です。
その実態がインターネット上にあるからこそ、スマートフォン、スマートウォッチ、パソコンなど、私たちが持つ、あらゆるデバイスからアクセスが可能になるのです。
頭に入れておかなければいけないのは、「エーアイアシスタント」の実態は、ジーピーティーやClaudeのような「エーアイモデル」ではないという点です。
エーアイアシスタントとして良い仕事をするためには、使う本人のことを良く「知っている・理解している」必要があり、そのためには、過去の会話の記憶はもちろん、予定表・住所録・ToDoリスト・メール・ミーティングメモ・日記などその人が蓄積しているさまざまなデータにアクセスすることも必要だし、その人が使っている（もしくは必要に応じて作った）アプリのことも熟知している必要があります。
オープンエーアイやアンソロピックがGhatGPTやClaudeにメモリー機能を追加しているのは当然そこを狙ってのことだし、実際にユーザーのデータの多くを握っているメタやグーグルもそこに標的を定めています。
しかし、個人のデータやアプリをすべて抱えて次々に蓄積して行くことになる「エーアイアシスタント」ほど重要なものを、特定のサービス・プロバイダーに任せてしまうのは賢くないと私は思います。
長く使えば使うほど、切り替えに伴う痛みが大きくなり、一生、そのサービスから離れられなくなってしまいます。
MulmoClaudeを使うと、「エーアイアシスタント」を自分のパソコンの上で「育てる」ことが可能になります。
MulmoClaude自体はオープンソースだし、その実態は自分のパソコンの上に蓄積されて行くので、そのデータも進化の方向も100％自分で決められますその運命は100％自分でコントロールすることが可能です（githubを使って、バックアップやバージョン管理をすると安心です）。
この「エーアイアシスタントを育てる」という感覚がとても重要です。
エーアイアシスタントは出来上がったものをどこかから買ってくるものではなく、自分で育てるものなのです。
インストールしたばかりのMulmoClaudeには何もデータが蓄積されていないし、自分専用のアプリも存在しません。
そのままでは「エーアイアシスタント」の役割は果たせません。
MulmoClaudeの中で動くエーアイ（現時点ではClaude Code）と自然言語で会話をしながら、自分専用のアプリを作り、さまざまなデータを蓄積して行く、それこそが「エーアイアシスタント」の正しい「育て方」だと私は思うのです。
エーアイがこれからの世の中でますます重要になることは明らかで、「エーアイを使いこなせる人」とそうでない人の間には、大きなギャップが生まれることは明らかです。
是非とも
MulmoClaude
をインストールし、自分専用のエーアイアシスタントを育て、「エーアイを使いこなせる側の人」になっていただきたいと思います。
トランプ・アカウント
少し前のメルマガに、日銀の溜め込んだイーティーエフのしょりの仕方として、新しく生まれてきた子どもにプレゼントしてしまうというアイデアを書きましたが、せんしゅう、それとよく似たプランをトランプ政権が発表したので少し驚きました。
名称は「Trump Account（トランプ口座）」と呼ばれ、2025年1月1日〜2028年12月31日に生まれた子ども全員に、連邦政府が1,000ドルを拠出する、というものです。
運用は、低コストのイーティーエフに限定され、親や祖父母、企業などが年間5,000ドルまで追加で入金できます。
基本的には18歳になるまで引き出せず、その後はIRAとして扱われます。
教育費や住宅購入などへの利用も想定されています。
「子どもの頃からかぶしきしじょうに参加し、資本主義の恩恵を受けられるようにする」ことを目的に共和党により推進された制度です。
政府の1,000ドルだけでは大きな資産になりにくい
追加拠出できる裕福な家庭ほど恩恵が大きい
トランプ氏の名前をつけた売名行為だ
との批判もありますが、悪くない制度だと思います。
私のアイデアとは規模も減資も異なりますが、生まれてくる子どもたちに株式を長期保有してもらおうという発想は、とても良いと思います。
ちょうど良い機会なので、いぜんメルマガで発表したアイデアを、note.comで「
オープンレター(日本政府への提言)：日銀の保有するイーティーエフを使って少子高齢化に歯止めをかける方法
」という形のオープンレター（日本政府への提言）として公開しました。
エーアイ時代の働き方
せんしゅうの質問に「エーアイを使いこなせる人たちになるためには、今のうちに何をすべきか」という質問がありました。
私も含めて、多くの人たちが「エーアイが人の職を奪うのではなく、エーアイを使いこなせる人たちが、使いこなせない人から職を奪う」と指摘しているためだと思います。
その場では、「技術職であるならば、まずは、Claude Code（もしくは、Codex、Antigravity）を使って仕事をするところからスタートしてください。
コーディングはもちろんのこと、資料作りから調査まで、githubのリポジトリ上でClaude Codeを走らせて仕事をするのが、現時点で最も有効な『これからの仕事の仕方』を学ぶのにいちばんの方法です。
」と答えましたが、具体性に欠けると感じたので、少し補足します。
まずさいしょに認識して欲しいのですが、既に「ChatGPTに質問・相談する」程度のことをしている人は、世の中に何億人もおり、それだけで「エーアイを使いこなせる側」に立てると思ったら大間違いです。
私自身も時々ChatGPTを使いますが、主に使うのは調べものと文章の添削ぐらいで、トークン使用量（エーアイの使用量を測るのに最も適した尺度です）で言えば、全体の５％以下で、大半はClaude Codeを使ったコーディングです。
ソフトウェア・エンジニア以外でも、エーアイを単なるチャット以外の方法で活用している人たちはたくさんいるので、いくつか紹介します。
一番簡単な例は、ChatGPTに対して単に質問を投げてそれで答えを得ようとするのではなく、ChatGPTを相手にさまざまな意見を交換する「壁打ち」です。
自分が考えていることを書いて、評価してもらっても良いし、逆にChatGPTにアイデアを書かせて、それをこちらが評価するのもありです。
単なる「質問箱」ではなく、「議論する相手」として扱うだけでも大きな違いが出ます。
ChatGPTに資料を渡して、それを要約させたり翻訳することも良く行われていると思いますが、その一歩先の応用としては、資料を渡した上で、ChatGPTが先生になったつもりで色々と質問するのも良い勉強法になります。
要約を読んで分からない部分があったらさらに質問すれば良いし、質問をさらに深めてで知識を広げるのも良い手法です。
資料をベースに質問する場合は、グーグルの
NotebookLM
がお勧めです。
調べたい・学びたいトピックに関連する複数の情報を一つのNotebookに放り込み、それらの情報を踏まえた上での質疑応答をしたり、資料を作らせるにはとても良い環境です。
NotebookLMは、Youtubeの中身も調べて解説してくれるので、長尺のYoutubeビデオを観る時間がない時などにはとても便利です。
ChatGPTやClaudeには、エーアイが作った資料を置くことができるCanvas/Artifactという機能があり、これを使うと、会話をしながら人間とエーアイが協力して資料やアプリを作ることが可能になります。
Claude Codeが誕生するまでは、私はこの機能を結構使っていましたが、Claude Codeはまだ敷居が高いと感じている人には、悪くないツールだと思います。
ここまでであれば、ソフトウェア・エンジニア以外の人でも簡単に出来ると思います。
しかし、これだけではこれからの時代「エーアイを使いこなす側」に立つのはとても難しいと思います。
ここで一気に敷居が高くなってしまいますが、私のおすすめはClaude Codeです。
Claude Codeはソフトウェア・エンジニア向けに作られたツールですが、Gitというソフトウェアと組み合わせて使うと、上に書いたCanvas/Artifactで行っていた資料作りのようなことが、バージョン管理や他人との共有も含めて、本格的に行えるようになります。
Gitは、元々はエンジニアがソースコードを管理するために作られたソフトですが、普通のドキュメントの資料の管理にもとても便利なツールで、私もメルマガの執筆に活用しています。
Gitに関しては、
エンジニア以外が覚える Git のはなし #GitHub
【非エンジニア向け】宇宙一わかりやすいGitことはじめ
エーアイと働く時代のGit/GitHub入門─ 非エンジニアが「怖がらずに使う」ための20の学び
のような資料がネット上にはたくさんありますが、一番良いのは、ChatGPTやClaudeに「gitの使い方を教えて」と尋ねながら、実際に使ってみるのが１番の近道です。
Gitは自分のパソコンだけで使うことも可能ですが、基本的にはマイクロソフトが提供する
Github
というサービスを使って、リポジトリと呼ばれるファイル一式のバックアップを作ったり、それを通して他人と共有する使い方がいっぱん的です。
Claude Codeは、git + github でソースコードを管理する人たちのために作られているため、通常の文章であっても、Claude Code + git + github を組み合わせて使うと、最強なのです。
そうは書いても、gitでくじけてしまう人が多いとは思いますが、ここは是非とも乗り越えてください。
「エーアイを使いこなす側」に立つための、いちばんさいしょの関門だと考えてください。
この関門を越えることができると、「エーアイを活用してできること」の幅が一気に増え、自分自身の生産性が大きく向上したように感じられるようになります。
Claude Codeを「git + github」と組み合わせて使えるようになったら、特定の会社に関する調査でも、マーケティング計画でも、小説でもなんでも良いので、自分が興味を持てるトピックの資料をClaude Codeと一緒に作ってみてください。
Claude Codeには、上に書いたCanvas/Artifactのようなドキュメントの表示機能を持ち合わせていないので、さいしょは少し戸惑うと思いますが、マイクロソフト Visual StudioのようなIDE(統合開発環境)やテキストエディターと組み合わせて使うと、その良さが次第に分かってくると思います。
「自分でアプリを作る経験」をしてみたいと考える人には、私が開発している
MulmoClaude
を是非とも試していただきたいと思います。
MulmoClaudeは、せんしゅう書いた通り、
仕事や生活の面で必要なものを記録・記憶してくれる
様々な情報を調査・要約・整理・プレゼン・解説してくれる
様々な機能を自然言語で指示するだけで付け加えることができる
エーアイネイティブなツールで、使いこなすと、仕事と生活の両面に必要なさまざまな情報をパソコン上に保持してくれる「自分だけのエーアイアシスタント」になってくれるように作られています。
これまでは、カレンダー、ToDoリスト、住所録、株のポートフォリオ管理、買い物メモ、食事ログ、仕事ログ、日記、単語帳、などのさまざまなアプリは、アプリストアからダウンロードしたり、そんなサービスを提供するウェブサイトにアカウントを作って使うのがいっぱん的でしたが、MulmoClaude上では、その手のアプリはエーアイに依頼するだけで簡単に作ってもらうことが可能です。
なんでも作ってもらえるとは言え、どう依頼すれば良いのかさいしょは戸惑うでしょうから、さいしょは用意されているテンプレートから適当なものを選んでもらうのが良いと思います。
「コレクション」というページで右上の「+コレクション」というボタンを押すと、下のようなメニューが表示されるので、まずはサンプルプロントの一つを選んで試していただくのが良いと思います。
Tesla車を買う理由の変化
TeslaのFSDがついに「人間の運転手よりも安全」なレベルに達したという話は少し前に書きましたが、それがFSD（自動運転機能）の装着率の上昇だけでなく、Tesla車の売り上げに繋がっているとするX上の投稿を目にしました。
[EN]Something is happening. $TSLA[/EN]
考えてみれば当然のことです。
自動車の運転は誰にとっても結構なストレスで、毎朝、小一時間かけて会社との往復をしている人にとってみれば、そのストレスを排除するだけで仕事にも生活にも大きなプラスになります。
特に家に帰る時間が遅くなった際には、眠気とも戦わなければならないため、そのメリットを考えればFSDを使わない手はないと思います。
FSDの利用料は月額99ドルですが、疲れている時にも安全に自分の家まで送り届けてくれる「お抱え運転手」だと思えば、安いものです。
Elon Muskが大統領選の際にトランプ氏を支援したことが、Teslaブランドを大きく傷つけ、さらにそのトランプ氏が連邦政府による電気自動車向けの補助金を廃止したため、この2年ほどは売り上げが停滞したTeslaですが、FSDの価値をより多くの人たちが理解するようになれば、それがTesla車を購入する理由になると（長期でTesla株を保有している）私は期待しています。
ちなみに、私の知り合いにアパート向けの充電設備を販売するビジネスをしている人がいますが、Teslaの中古車がしじょうに出回り出した結果、アパートに暮らす若い人たちが中古のTesla車を安く入手できるようになり、充電じゅようが急増しているそうです。
しじょうに出回った中古車が、サブスクリプション・ビジネスに結びつくというところも、これまでの自動車業界には存在しなかったビジネスモデルです。
[EN]NVIDIAとPalantirの提携[/EN]
先日、エヌビディアとPalantirが提携を発表しました。
[EN]Open Models, Closed Environments: Palantir Brings Secure AI to US Agencies With NVIDIA Nemotron[/EN]
エヌビディアは、さまざまな企業との提携を発表しているので、この発表を見ただけではそれほど大きなニュースとは思えませんが、中国製エーアイの台頭、少し前に起こった米国政府とアンソロピックの間の軋轢、トークン・コストに神経質になり始めた企業を踏まえた上で、さいきんのAlex Karp(アンソロピック シーイーオー)の発言を聞いていると、結構大きな話であることが見えて来ます。
ご存知の通り、現時点でエーアイモデルの最前線（フロンティア）を走るのは、オープンエーアイ、アンソロピック、グーグルの三社です。
それぞれとくいな分野は異なりますが、ビジネスにエーアイを活用するとなると、この三つの中から選ぶのがいっぱん的です。
米軍にエーアイを活用した情報収集サービスなどを提供しているPalantirは、これまで主にアンソロピックのエーアイモデルを活用していましたが、実際に米軍との契約の段階になり、武器などへの利用を嫌がったアンソロピック側が米軍との契約を拒み、結果として、トランプ政権にブラックリストに入れられてしまうという事態にすらなりました。
オープン・ウェイトなモデルの性能も上昇しているため、将来はそちらに切り替えるべきと考える企業も少なくありません。
トークン・コストのこともありますが、彼らのエーピーアイサービスを利用すると企業内のデータやノウハウが彼らに流れてしまう点が一番の懸念です。
しかし、オープン・ウェイトなモデルの大半は、中国製であり、中国共産党の価値観に合わせて作られたエーアイモデルを西側で使うのは間違っていると考える人も少なくありません（私もその一人です）。
そんな中で今回、Palantirは、エヌビディアが提供するオープン・ウェイトなモデル Nemotron を全面的に採用し、クローズドなエーアイモデルにも、中国製のオープン・モデルにも頼らない、エーアイサービスを米国政府に提供すると宣言したのです。
エヌビディアにとって、オープンエーアイ、アンソロピック、グーグルの三社は、最大の顧客なので、表立って彼らに対抗することはしたくないので、まずは Nemotron をさらに成長させて中国のオープン・モデルに対抗するのはもちろん、これら三社のエーアイサービスに縛られない形のエーアイモデルを、Palantirを通じて米国政府に提供することになったのです。
アンソロピックだけでなく、オープンエーアイ、グーグル内にもエーアイモデルを軍事利用することに反対する声が多いため、（西側の企業である）NVIDAが提供するオープンウェイトな Nemotron を活用して、Palantirが軍事利用するというのは、悪くない落とし所に私には見えます。
Palantirとしては、これを足がかりに、一般企業に対しても、オープンウェイトなモデルを使ったPalantirのソリューションを売り込みたいと考えているのは当然で、そこでも Nemotron が大きな役割を果たす可能性が十分にあるように私には見えます。
私の目に留まった記事
Tesla、Optimus部品の具体的な調達目標をサプライヤーに提示か
Teslaがヒューマノイドロボット「Optimus」の部品について、具体的な調達目標をついにサプライヤー（部品供給業者）に提示した、というサプライチェーン（部品の供給網）内部の情報筋によるX上の投稿です。
投稿によると、Teslaはサプライヤーに対し、ことし9月までに週1,000台分、年末までに週2,000〜2,500台分の部品を生産できる体制を整えるよう求めているとのことです。
[EN]Here is the title: Weekly Life is Beautiful July 14, 2026 Issue: AI Assistant Training Tool, Trump Account, Working Styles in the AI Era, Change in Reasons for Buying Tesla Cars, NVIDIA and Palantir Partnership (Part 3/5)[/EN]
まず、Teslaについてです。
Teslaは通常、2ヶ月前に発注を行うそうですが、すでに8月分として数百台分の具体的な発注が確認されています。
この計算によれば、12月末までにサプライチェーン全体で年間10万台分のOptimus部品を供給できる能力が整うことになります。
また、この大量発注を確定する前の6月下旬に、Elon Musk自身が最新版のOptimusをレビューして承認したとされており、3年以上の研究開発期間を経て、第3世代のOptimus Gen 3がようやく研究室を出て量産段階に入ることを意味しているんです。
さらに、その会議の席でElon Muskは「年末の生産目標を達成できなければ、Optimusの調達部門を全員解雇する」と最後通告を突きつけたそうです。
こうした強硬な姿勢が、無難な標準的予測よりもはるかにサプライチェーンや市場、ロボット業界全体に自信を与えるものだと述べています。
最近はTeslaからOptimusに関する情報があまり出ていませんでしたが、このリーク記事を読む限り順調に進んでいるようです。
初年度から年産10万台というのは、かなり積極的な数字ですが、自社の工場で実際に使い、そこで集まったデータでAIをさらに強化する計画なので、このくらいは必要なのだと思います。
続いての話題は中国についてです。
[EN]China fired a shot heard around the world[/EN]という状況ですが、中国がヒト型ロボットの生産と価格破壊で世界を圧倒し始めており、「物理世界のAI軍拡競争」で先行している、と指摘する投稿があります。
この投稿によると、中国は2025年に世界の産業用ロボット導入の54パーセントを占めていたり、ヒト型ロボットについては12,870台を生産し、世界の導入台数の80パーセント以上を占めたということです。
特に注目すべきなのは価格の下落スピードで、Unitreeという中国のロボットメーカーのヒト型ロボットは2023年の約1,300万円から2025年末には約375万円へと6〜7割も値下がりし、最新のR1モデルに至っては約73万円と、中古車並みの価格になっています。
なぜ中国がこれほど速く動けるかというと、既存のサプライチェーンの存在が挙げられます。
中国のヒト型ロボット企業の半数以上は、電気自動車や家電のサプライチェーンとそのまま重なっており、自動車向けに作られていたモーターやギア、アクチュエーターといった部品を、新しい工場を建てることなくロボットに転用しているのです。
さらに、政府の誘導ファンドがこの分野にことしだけで約3〜4.5兆円を投じており、上海市は2030年までに10万台の工場向けロボット配備を目標にしています。
投稿は、中国がAIソフトウェアの競争では米国に負けつつあることを自覚しているからこそ、物理レイヤー、つまりロボットの本体を握ることにすべてを賭けている、と分析しています。
2025年時点で中国のAgiBotが世界シェアの39パーセント、Unitreeが32パーセントと、中国企業だけで市場の約8割を占め、2026年には中国のヒト型ロボット生産はさらに94パーセント増加すると予測されています。
米国側の対応はまだ固まっていませんが、半導体やEVの時と同じように、TeslaのOptimusやFigure AIなどの米国メーカーへの政府補助金が出ることになるだろう、という見立てです。
2026年後半に量産開始が見込まれるTesla Optimus Gen 3が、サプライチェーンと資本市場を大きく揺さぶる可能性があると締めくくっています。
一方、別のところで、TeslaはOptimusに必要な部品の多くを中国から調達すると読んだ記憶があり、少し懸念しています。
このメルマガでも何度も指摘していますが、中国に変わる「西側のサプライチェーン」の構築を目指すことが、米国の同盟国である日本や韓国にとっては理にかなった戦略だと思います。
続いては、Syntiantについてです。
[EN]Syntiant files for a US IPO, betting public markets want edge AI too[/EN]という報道がありました。
イヤホンやスマートウォッチの中でAIを動かす半導体を作るSyntiantが、IPOを申請したということです。
この会社は2017年に創業され、カリフォルニア州アーバインに本社を構える半導体企業で、Intelとマイクロソフトのベンチャー投資部門が出資しています。
エヌビディアのようにデータセンター向けの巨大なAIチップを作るのではなく、その正反対の「エッジAI」が主戦場で、ボタン電池で動くほど消費電力の小さいNDPという専用チップを累計1億個以上出荷しています。
例えばこのチップは、イヤホンが「ヘイ、○○」という呼びかけの声だけを聞き分けて本体を起こすといった常時待ち受けの処理を、極めて小さな電力で実現するものです。
7月6日に提出された上場申請書類によると、上場先はNasdaqでティッカーは「SYTN」、主幹事はCitigroup、BofA、UBSの3社だそうです。
株式数や価格はまだ未定ですが、調達額は三億ドル規模と推定されています。
開示された最近の業績は、四半期売上六千四百五十万ドルで前年同期比3.2パーセント減、純損失は前年から拡大しています。
「AIブームに乗った上場だが、足元の数字はむしろ減速している」との指摘もあるんです。
売上の内容にも注意が必要です。
Syntiantは2024年末に、マイク業界の老舗Knowlesからスマホやイヤホンに入る超小型のMEMSマイク事業を一億五千万ドルで買収しました。
そのため、現在の売上の大半はこのマイク事業によるものです。
同社は「音が生まれるマイクにAIチップを組み込み、マイク自身が賢くなる」という統合戦略を掲げていますが、マイクは利幅の薄い量産部品のビジネス。
AI半導体企業としての評価がどこまで得られるかは、しじょうの審判を待つことになります。
エッジAI企業の上場としては、超低消費電力チップのAmbiq Micro（2025年7月）、ウェハースケールの巨大チップで知られるCerebras（2026年5月）に続く動きです。
一方、同じエッジAIでもイスラエルのHailoは今年6月にSPAC上場が破談となり、従業員の半数を解雇しています。
明暗が分かれている状況です。
SyntiantのIPOが成功すれば、「データセンターの外」で動くAI半導体への投資家の関心を測る良い試金石になりそうですね。
[EN]Memory-on-Logic: Re-Rating Memory Beyond the Cycle[/EN]に関する投資分析記事もあります。
「メモリ半導体はもはや景気循環型のコモディティではなく、カスタム半導体パートナーへと進化しつつある」と主張しています。
これまでメモリ半導体は、好況と不況を繰り返す循環産業と見なされてきました。
しかし、AI向けメモリの技術進化がこの前提を壊しつつあるとの指摘です。
進化の段階は3つあります。
まずはHBM、広帯域メモリで、標準規格品としてジーピーユーの隣に置いて接続する方式です。
次に、カスタムHBMというものがあります。
これは顧客企業専用の回路をメモリの土台部分に組み込んだもので、業界標準規格から離れるため、他社製品との交換がきかなくなるんです。
最後に、Memory-on-Logicというものがあります。
メモリを計算チップの真上に直接積み上げる方式で、中継役の部品が不要になり、データ転送能力は64倍、電力効率は3倍になるとのことです。
すでにSK hynix、Samsung、Micronの3社は、2028年に登場するエヌビディアの次世代ジーピーユー「Feynman」に向けてカスタムHBMの開発を進めており、Qualcommも2027年半ばにHBCと呼ぶ製品の投入を計画中です。
マイクロソフトやサウジアラビアのAI企業であるHumainも、これらの製品を採用するか検討しています。
顧客専用の回路を組み込んだメモリは、価格競争に晒される汎用品とは違い、長期契約と高い利益率が見込めるビジネスになります。
筆者は、現在のメモリ企業の株価はこの「収益構造の変化」を織り込んでおらず、循環産業としての古い物差しで評価されたままだ、と結論づけています。
ことしになって大きく高騰したメモリ関連株がこんごも値上がりし続けるのか、近いうちにピークが来るのかは、アナリストたちの間でも意見が別れています。
私は、SpaceXがじょうじょうする際に、所有しているマイクロンの株は全部売却してしまいましたが、あの時点（約$1000）がピークだと思ったわけではなく、単に、「ここで売却してピークを逃しても良い」と思っただけのことです。
株の売り時は本当に難しいと思います。
[EN]Introducing Muse Image and Muse Video[/EN]
メタによる画像・映像生成エーアイの発表です。
オープンエーアイのジーピーティー Image 2にはまだ追いついていないようですが、グーグルのNano Banana 2/Proを人間が評価するベンチマークで超えている点は評価できます。
ここのところ、オープンエーアイ vs. アンソロピックの戦いばかりが注目されており、メタは グーグル や xAIにも負けている「番外」のようなイメージがありましたが、これでようやく戦線復帰をした感があります。
久しぶりに覗いてみると、ChatGPTやClaudeを強く意識した
メタ エーアイ
もかなり使いやすくなっているし、Zackerbergがかなり危機感を持ってここに力を入れていることが分かります。
私自身は、さいきんはFacebookもInstagramもほぼアクセスしなくなっているので、その意味で、メタとの距離は遠ざかっているように感じます。
一番の接点が、メタのスマートグラスですが、これも毎日使うようなデバイスではありません。
[EN]NEO's Hands: An API to the Physical World[/EN]
ヒト型ロボット「NEO」をかいはつする1X Technologiesが、人間の手に迫る器用さを持つ25自由度（DoF。
関節が独立に動ける方向の数）の「腱駆動ハンド」を発表したブログ記事です。
1Xは、ヒト型ロボットを「手がエーピーアイ（外部との接点となるインターフェース）になっているコンピューター」と捉えています。
従来のロボットの多くは「掴む・置く・押す」程度しかできないシンプルなグリッパー（挟むだけの爪）を持つだけでしたが、手が人間並みに器用になれば、こなせる仕事の範囲が爆発的に広がる、というのが彼らの主張です。
技術面での最大のポイントは「力の透明性」です。
従来のロボットハンドは100:1〜200:1という大きな減速比のギアを使うため、モーターから指先までの間で力の感覚が失われてしまいます。
NEOの手は5:1〜15:1という小さな減速比の腱駆動（人間の腱のようにワイヤーで指を動かす方式）を採用しており、25の関節すべてが力を制御でき、外から押されると素直に動く「バックドライバブル」な構造になっています。
これにより、手が「動かす」と「感じる」を同時にこなせるのです。
指先には、押す力・接触位置・ずれ（滑り）を測るタッチセンサーが組み込まれており、物が滑り始めたら即座に握り直すといった反応も可能です。
デモでは、レゴの組み立て、ネジやコインの操作、ドライバーや電球の扱い、ブドウや折り紙やワイングラスといった壊れやすい物の取り扱い、ジャケットのファスナー閉め、手話まで披露しています。
防水（IP68）で食品に触れても安全な素材を使い、手首の関節は200万回以上の動作試験をクリアしているとのことです。
モーターと腱は人間の解剖学と同じく前腕に収められ、モーターから腱、柔らかいポリマー、触覚センサーまですべて自社製造で、年間1万本の手を生産できる体制だとしています。
記事の締めくくりで1Xは「大量生産できない手では、大規模な実験ができない。
大規模なデータなしには、身体を持つAGI（汎用人工知能）は実現しない」と述べています。
器用な手で行うすべての作業が、力や触覚の記録付きの学習データになる、つまり手そのものがエーアイの学習装置になる、という戦略です。
人型ロボットしじょうは投資対象としても注目しているし、私自身も入手したいと考えているので、この手の記事はワクワクして読んでしまいます。
特に「手」は人の体の中でもっとも高度なことができる器官なので、人型ロボットに人間の代わりに仕事をさせようと考える場合には、避けて通ることができない、重要な部分です。
実は、日本の製造業を応援するために「ロボコン」を開催しようと考えていますが、その際には、人型ロボット全体ではなく、手の器用さだけを競うロボコンにして、中小企業の技術者たちが、社長決済なしでチャレンジできるぐらいの規模にすることが重要だと考えています。
質問コーナー
【質問】
現在、大学院で分散システム、特にコンセンサスアルゴリズムについて学んでいます。
こんごの研究テーマを考える中で、単に既存プロトコルの改良を追うだけでなく、これから重要になりそうな応用領域や、長期的に研究する価値のある問題設定を見つけたいと考えています。
中島さんから見て、こんご5〜10年で、分散システムやコンセンサスの研究者が注目すべきテーマや応用先はどのあたりにあると思われますか？
《回答》
コンセンサスアルゴリズムと聞いてさいしょに頭に浮かんだのはブロックチェーンの技術です。
とても良い技術ですが、やたらと電力を食うのが問題だし、暗号通貨をベースにしたビジネスが、すべてポンジー・スキームになってしまうのが致命的な欠陥です。
私がこの分野での研究をするとしたら、通貨の発行を伴わない（つまり、ポンジー・スキームにならない）形で、分散データベースを可能にすることができないかを考えるだろうと思います。
私が開発しているMulmoClaudeには、複式簿記の機能がありますが、これを複数のマシンで並行して走らせ（誰もが悪意は持っていないと仮定します）、後からgithubなどを介してマージする場合に、どうやってマージするか、マージできないケースが生じた場合、（人間を介入させても良いので）どう解決すべきか、などは私自身にとっては、実用的で興味深いテーマです。
【質問】
エーアイ創薬についての質問となります。
少し抽象的にはなりますが、エーアイ創薬における本質的なお金の動きとして「大手企業のR&D費用がエーアイネイティブな会社に流れる」のではないかと捉えております。
起点にはエーアイの登場によって創薬最大のボトルネックだった試行錯誤のコストが劇的に下がることが起点になっていると思いますが、それがビジネス的な視点でこんご登場するエーアイネイティブな企業にどういった形で売上や利益が流れると中島さんはトレンドを捉えられていますでしょうか？
《回答》
理想的には、創薬の開発コストや時間が大幅に削られ（例えば10分の1）、結果として薬の値段も安くなりますが、必ずしも同じ比率では安くならず（例えば5分の1）、その差額が、エーアイ技術を提供した会社にロイヤリティとして入る、という形が一番だと思います。
私がDemis Hassabisであれば、そんなビジネス関係を製薬会社と結ぶだろうと思います。
【質問】
このメルマガを読んでるうちに自分でもエーアイで何かアプリを作りたくなってきた44歳おじさんです。
体重管理やオセロなど作成中です。
おとなが楽しめるマイクラのようで、面白いです。
質問は、ソフトバンクの株をいぜんは持っていたが手放した理由は何でしょうか。
アンソロピックの方が勝ちそうな気がしたからでしょうか。
《回答》
ソフトバンクの株を持っていたのは随分前ですが、WeWorkへの投資が失敗し、エヌビディアの株とBoston Dynamicsを売却せざるをえなかった頃だと思います。
そんさんは目の付け所が良いだけでなく、あの手の失敗の後にもちゃんと不死鳥のごとく立ち直ってくるところだと思います。
【質問】
「MulmoClaudeとは何か？
」を読んでの感想
最終的には、この問いに対して、中島さんご自身は「オンデマンドでソフトウェアそのものを生成するオーエス」と表現されていましたが、目的・価値という観点では、私はVisiCalcとの類似性を強く感じました。
当初は、
仕事や生活の面で必要なものを記録・記憶してくれる
様々な情報を調査・要約・整理・プレゼン・解説してくれる」
というあたりから、プログラマブルなノートという比喩が浮かんでいました。
しかし、最後まで読み終わって、VisiCalcとの類似性を本質だと感じています。
両方とも、専門家しか享受できなかった「自分でプログラミングすること」の恩恵を、いっぱんの人にも開放した点が特に類似していると思います。
表計算ソフトも様々な用途に使われますが、プログラミング的な部分が数式に限定されていました。
いっぽうで、MulmoClaudeは自然言語に表現が広がったことで、用途がさらに広がると思います。
この ”誰でもプログラミングの便利さを享受できる” という点が、重要で、オーバーに表現すると、VisiCalcはプログラミング能力の民主化をしたと言えます。
最近、エーアイによるばいぶコーディングが、そのような評価をされていますが、少し違和感があります。
ばいぶコーディングは、BASICなどの高級言語がそうであったように、「プログラムを書く人」の敷居を下げる進化だと感じるからです。
VisiCalcは、プログラムを書けない人でもプログラミングの恩恵を受けられるようにした点で、本当の意味で「プログラミング能力を民主化した」ソフトウェアだったと感じます。
MulmoClaudeも同じ系譜にあり、自然言語によってその対象をさらに広げ、「誰でもソフトウェアを作れる世界」に近づけているように感じました。
《回答》
丁寧なコメント、ありがとうございます。
確かに「ばいぶ・コーディングを民主化する」というポジショニングも悪くないと思うので、資料などを作るときに参考にさせていただきます。
【質問】
中1の娘がpythonの学習をしています。
cloude codeが進化するとコーティングそのものは私たちの仕事ではなくなり、テストですらエーアイが代わりに行って人がやる部分は少なくなると、こんしゅうの質問コーナーで中島さんはご回答されています。
であるなら、これからの子供たちにこの分野の学習をさせるなら、中島さんなら何をさせますか？
そもそもプログラミング学習そのものに価値はありますか？
《回答》
確かに、人間がプログラミングをする場面は減りつつありますが、プログラミング学習そのものには大きな価値があると思います。
電卓やパソコンが身近なものになったからと言って、算数の勉強が不要になってはいないのと同じで、自分自身でプログラミングを経験することは、エーアイがコードを書く時代になっても重要です。
【質問】
日々の知的生産のバランスについて相談です。
私は視野を広げるための新聞6紙のチェックや、ビジネス・マーケティングの独学を日課にしています。
しかし、完璧主義の傾向があり、仕事が多忙な時期でも、すべて予定通りにこなそうとしてしまい、睡眠やリフレッシュの時間を真っ先に犠牲にしてしまいます。
中島さんは、仕事やインプットにおいて「どこで合格点として切り上げるか」という基準をどう設定されていますか？
完璧主義を脱し、健康やパフォーマンスを維持しながら持続可能な優先順位をつけるためのアドバイスをいただきたいです。
《回答》
私の場合は、常に「締め切りに間に合う」ことを最優先にしているため、「完成度8割のものをまずは前倒しで作る」ことにより、余裕を持って仕事をするようにしています。
なので、それが十分に早くできていない場合にはストレスが溜まりますが、本当の締め切り前に慌てたりはしないようにしています。
8割以降の完成度に関しては、時間に余裕があれば行うし、なければ8割のものでとりあえず前に進めてしまいます。
【質問】
Claude Codeの実装スピードと確認・検査負担の関係についてご質問させていただきましたところ、こんしゅう号でご丁寧に回答いただきありがとうございました。
人間側の負担が相対的に減るいっぽうで、生産性の爆発的向上ゆえに暇にはならないというお話、私自身の実感とも重なりました。
さて、こんしゅう号の「Life-Harness」のご紹介の中で、MulmoClaudeはClaude Codeの上にコレクションという仕組みを載せることで、自分専用のデータベース・アプリを作れるようにしているとお書きになっていた点が、特に印象に残りました。
そこでお伺いしたいのですが、MulmoClaudeにおけるハーネスは、それ自体が価値の中心なのでしょうか。
それとも、ハーネスそのものはあくまで足場であり、実際の価値は、その上に蓄積されるデータや業務ルール、実行結果や修正履歴の方にあるのでしょうか。
あるいは、さいしょはハーネス自体が価値を生む入口になり、使い込むほどに、価値の中心がハーネスそのものから、その上に蓄積されたデータや判断履歴へ移っていく、という構造に近いのでしょうか。
私自身も、エーアイに作業を任せるためのプロンプトやツール定義はすぐ真似できても、実際に運用して得られた失敗ログや判断基準は簡単には真似できないのではないかと感じています。
その意味で、ハーネスの価値は「仕組みそのもの」にあるのか、「使われながら何を蓄積するか」にあるのかが気になりました。
《回答》
MulmoClaudeのハーネスはそれ自身に価値がありますが、もっと重要なのは、その上にユーザーが作るデータ＋アプリケーションの集合体であり、結果として構築される「特定のユーザー向けのエーアイアシスタント」です。
つまり、MulmoClaudeが提供する価値はあくまで「足場」であり、足場には足場の価値があるものの、その上に建てられる建物こそが最終的に価値を生み出すものになると考えて良いと思います。
【質問】
前回アマゾン（Trainium／Inferentia）についての紹介がありましたが、長期的にみてアマゾンの将来の展望をどうお考えですか？
個人的にはヒューマノイドロボット量産やドローン配達による配送費の劇的な削減によりecommerceの独壇場などヒューマノイドロボットによる恩恵を最も受けられる企業の一社になると考え得ています。
テスラやスペースXほど将来への過度な期待が株価に織り込まれおらず割高ではない、将来のポテンシャルが過小評価されている気がします。
《回答》
アマゾンほどに成長した企業のこんごを占うのは簡単ではありませんが、ご指摘の通り、ロボットやドローンによる流通の効率化の波が来ることは明らかで、その中で、きぼが大きく、かつ、技術力の高いアマゾンが優位な立場にあるのは確かだと思います。
まもなくじょうじょうするアンソロピックの大株主でもあるし、自社製エーアイチップへの投資も積極的に行っているので、まだまだ伸びる可能性は十分にあると思います（私は、アマゾン株の長期保有者です）。
【質問】
ご存知かもしれませんが、The Incredible Shrinking Transistorの、"Plenty of Room at the Bottom"という締めくくりのタイトルは、リチャード・ファインマンの講演の引用ですね。
ナノテクノロジーという概念や微細化の重要性を早くに予言（？
）したものとされているそうです。
これほど昔のビジョンが現在ですらまだ有効というのは感動的です。
《回答》
ファインマン博士は尊敬している人の一人ですが、この発言は知りませんでした。
教えていただき、感謝します。
確かに感動的な発言ですね。
さすがです。
以上で今回の放送を終わります。
またお聞きください。